géographie collège visitation la
dernière aujourd'hui la schématisation
comme support et références de cette
vidéo vous pouvez utiliser la fiche
technique numéro dix proposées au cours
mais surtout le site de monsieur jacques
muni d'un professeur de géographie qui
est vraiment le maître de la
schématisation et du croquis
géographique un schéma cartographiques
c'est une carte avec un thème qui est
simplifiée ici à l'écran vous voyez par
exemple la répartition de la population
aux états unis vous voyez que par
rapport à la carte du haut qui peut être
la carte sur laquelle on s'est basé pour
réaliser le schéma le schéma est
simplifiée il est simplifié à la fois au
niveau des contours des frontières vous
voyez que toutes les petites nuances
qu'on peut voir ici mais elles sont
effacées on va au plus simple et
l'information est également simplifiée
exemple ici en californie plusieurs fois
et population sur mon charme schéma 4
cartographie je vais tout représenter de
manière continue par exemple le schéma
karting cartographique permet une
meilleure compréhension
c'est beaucoup plus facile à comprendre
que la carte originale où l'information
est plus complexe
cependant dans certains cas la
schématisation sera trop importante
vous voyez qu ici entre la
schématisation à gauche et la carte qui
aurait pu servir de référence à cette
schématisation il ya quand même de
grosses différences
ici j'ai quand même des formes
caractéristiques à la france que je ne
vais pas retrouver ici puisque en fait
vous voilà ma france comment elle aurait
dû être mieux schématiser
avant moi montrer ici aller qu'on n'est
pas meilleure mais vous avez compris
l'idée pour que la schématisation soit
réussie il faut bien s'appliquer lorsque
l'on va schématiser le territoire je
vous propose un petit exercice a réalisé
cette semaine et a présenté au prochain
cours de géographie nous allons baser
sur la séquence de cours que nous voyons
actuellement et notamment sur l'île de
manhattan qui est le centre historique
de la ville de new york que vous pouvez
utiliser les planches qui sont proposés
dans la place on peut directement
évidemment se baser sur d'autres
projections comme une image d'origine
satellite
il faut commencer tout d'abord pour
schématiser a retrouvé des axes qui vont
permettre de construire le schéma
évidemment cet axe c'est vous qui
choisissez vous d'essayer de voir un
petit peu
quelles sont les plus grandes lignes que
vous pouvez tracer dans le territoire
dont on commence à schématiser le mieux
c'est directement de tracer ces lignes
sur une copie de la carte originale
nous on peut vraiment bien s'entraîner
avant les 1 par rapport à cet axe
principal
je vais trouver d'autres axes
secondaires je désire qu'ils soient au
maximum perpendiculaire entre eux voyez
ici avec six segments six ou sept
segments
j'ai déjà la structure de l'île de
manhattan
je vais reporter cette structure sur la
feuille sur laquelle je veux réaliser la
schématisation je respecte les
dimensions si le segment principal
mesure 5 cm je vais garder 5 cm et puis
je vais tracé celui ci il fait peut-être
un demi centimètre et ensuite à la même
distance
il y assure
mon document de référence je vais tracé
sur ma feuille où je vais schématiser
exactement la même distance je vais
faire exactement voyez les mêmes vax je
vais tenter ici la schématisation en
main levée à l'ordinateur évidemment
c'est pas l'idéal vous sur votre aide
vous devez vous appliquez mieux que ça
alors c'est parti voyez je vais vraiment
relier les différents actes comme je les
ai identifiés ici voilà un peu tourner
si je sais qu'à une petite courbure je
reviens ici ça va diminuer c'est pour ça
que j'ai mis les axes après et voici
c'est pas mal du tout ensuite on peut
évidemment effacés les axes principaux
pour qu'il n'apparaisse plus sur le
schéma est à ce moment là on a une
schématisation quelqu'un de relativement
réussies le site internet le monsieur il
ya nous propose beaucoup d'exemples de
schématisation et notamment si vous
allez visiter ce site je mettrais
plusieurs liens sur bleu geo
vous avez vraiment le pas à pas voyez
ici par exemple pour les états unis
on peut identifier des axes ici en verre
je repasse en rouge pour que vous les
voyez bien donc ça ça ce sont les axes
que monsieur muni dia a choisi il faut
bien sûr bien respecté les ordres veille
ce sont tous ces axes aussi envers je
m'amuse à repasser ici plus ou moins
rouge et à partir de ces axes et on peut
tracer vraiment le contour des états
unis comme il est fait ici en noir vous
me verrez sur toutes les références sur
le site view souhaite un bon travail et
à bientôt